Okay, so let's do this. We've taken a look
at our HTTP traffic from our client application. Let's go
back to the browser and see what it's doing differently.
We going to go look at the network request again and
if I scroll up, there's a cookie here, there's
some session data that is being maintained by the browser
and passed along. That's potentially at least part of the
problem, so. What we can do then is actually maintain
session state in our code. So what I've done
here is modified what we looked at before. And in
this case, we're going to use a session object
instead of just a request object to do both our
get and our post. We'll be using the same
session object, so any session information that we get back
from this first request, will be maintained and passed
along when we make this request. Alright, let's run this.
Let me go back to the browser and see if we've
got a correct response or a response that gives us back
the data we're hoping to get. And now we could see
that the data we get, is actually what we were expecting. So,
note that this is actually a local file and is in
fact the local file that we were writing out here. And
we've got the right settings here, what we would have expected
had we actually submitted this through the browser. And, we're pulling back
the data that we hoped to get. Still missing the CSS files, but we don't
care all we care about is this data right here. Whoo hoo! We did it!